[موسيقى]
عندما يؤثر على معدله الدراسي او يعني
مثلا يؤذيه دراسيا ما الطفل ما يقدر مثلا
يتعلم يصير المدرسه عنده شيء مؤذي اذا كان
مودي للطالب يعني في طرق يعني توصل
المعلومه للطالب بدون ما تجرحه الحين
العلم الحمد لله تطور
وتكنولوجيا متقدمه تقدر توصل للطالب
المعلومه بيسر سهوله بدون حناء
درالمين للاسف يعني صار رهاب علينا
للحين في معلمين يكرهم الان اشوفهم عندنا
بالديره والله اكرههم طبعا اذا اذا حصلت
الاذيه يعني سواء الاذيه النفسيه او
الاذيه
الجسديه اكيد سيكون الحزم هذا مؤذي
لما يصيب والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات